The New Mutants has gone down a bumpy road.
Fans weren't sure what to make of the X-Men
superhero/horror hybrid when the first trailer
dropped in October 2017.
To comics fans, it didn't look like the stories
they remembered.
The unfortunate flop Dark Phoenix brought
a lot of doubt into fans' minds, and rumors
about what Disney's acquisition of Fox would
mean for the fledgling spin-off franchise
began swirling.
Many questioned whether the movie would ever
see the light of day.
Well, it's been over two years since the first
trailer was released.
There have been lots of delays, but The New
Mutants is finally almost here.
The film's characters are based on the X-Men's
junior team, first introduced in 1982's original
graphic novel The New Mutants.
The team later enjoyed its own ongoing series,
which was revived in late 2019, and most of
the characters have remained mainstays in
the Marvel Comics universe ever since as members
of other mutant teams and in some cases, even
as Avengers.
With The New Mutants fast approaching and
with its production woes proving to be more
public than maybe the filmmakers and studio
would like we thought it would be good to
separate what we know from rumor.
Here's what we can tell you about the New
Mutants release date, the cast, the plot,
and a few others things we're guessing you're
curious about.
Considering the uncertainty that's surrounded
the production of The New Mutants, we're assuming
it's a bit of unintentional irony that the
movie will finally hit theaters two days after
April Fool's Day Friday, April 3, 2020.
"Well that doesn't mean anything!"
"Are you kidding?
That's very significant!"
It's been a long road securing that 2020 release
date.
The first New Mutants trailer emerged in October
2017, announcing a release date of April 13,
2018, which would have put it on theater screens
two weeks before Avengers: Infinity War.
Yet, the latter film and its sequel 2019's
Avengers: Endgame would prove to be insanely
successful pop culture landmarks without a
hint of New Mutants anywhere in sight.
The New Mutants' first delay pushed it back
to February 2019, but in March 2018 a month
before its original release date it was announced
the film had been pushed back again to August
2019.
Finally, in May 2019, Disney announced The
New Mutants would bring the X-Men's junior
team to the big screen on April 3, 2020...
and that they really, really meant it this
time.
"What can you tell us about The New Mutants?"
"...That, uh…
It's coming your way at some point."
Much speculation has surrounded The New Mutants'
massive delay, spending two years on the shelf
in a market that has been more than kind to
superhero movies.
No one can blame you for wondering exactly
why it's taken so long to get Marvel's younger
mutants to the big screen.
"Where are the mutants."
"Take another step, I'm gonna put you down."
"Put that man down or we will open fire!"
In January 2018, The Hollywood Reporter reported
that Fox had moved The New Mutants to February
2019 in order to give Deadpool 2 whose release
was moved up to May 2018 some elbow room.
After Dark Phoenix reshoots delayed that film's
release to February 2019, New Mutants was
once again bumped back to make room for the
12th chapter of the flagship X-Men film franchise,
this time to August 2019.
Throughout most of the film's delays, the
subject of reshoots kept popping up.
In March 2018, director Josh Boone was said
to be reshooting up to half the movie, possibly
even adding new characters.
Yet by March 2019, THR was reporting that
reshoots hadn't happened, and furthermore,
weren't planned.
A couple of months later, producer Simon Kinberg
asserted that reshoots were going to happen,
but that the schedules of all the actors created
a difficult juggling act.
In December 2019, after the final release
date was announced, director Josh Boone said
the finally finished New Mutants was actually
very close to his original vision of the project,
and his comments have left fans wondering
whether or not the long-reported reshoots
ever actually happened.
"Doesn't make any sense, does it?"
Perhaps the best known members of The New
Mutants' principal cast are Maisie Williams,
who played Arya Stark in HBO's Game of Thrones,
and Charlie Heaton, best known as social outcast
Jonathan Beyers on Netflix's Stranger Things.
Williams plays Rahne Sinclair, a.k.a. Wolfsbane
— a mutant with abilities that mimic the
powers of werewolves.
Heaton is Sam Guthrie, better known as Cannonball.
Guthrie is often portrayed as one of the team's
leaders, and in the comics has the ability
to blast himself into the air at unbelievable
speeds, remaining completely invulnerable
while in flight.
As for the rest of the team, there's Ilyana
Rasputin, a.k.a. Magik, played by Anya Taylor-Joy.
Magik has often been one of the edgier mutant
heroes in the comics, sometimes going into
the same dark anti-human territory, where
we find extremists like Magneto.
"Ilyana?"
"I killed 18 men.
One… by… one."
Henry Zaga plays Robert da Costa (a.k.a. Sunspot),
though this isn't the character's first big
screen appearance.
Adan Canto has a small role as Sunspot in
2014's X-Men: Days of Future Past.
Rounding out the lead cast is Blu Hunt, who
plays the illusion-conjuring Dani Moonstar,
a.k.a. Mirage.
Joining the New Mutants is Dr. Cecilia Reyes,
played by Alice Braga.
If the film follows the comics closely enough,
Dr. Reyes may prove to be a mutant just like
her patients.
In the comics, Dr. Reyes generates a biological
force field which she can use to defend herself
or to form shapes which she can use as weapons.
Along with the extensive reshoots originally
planned, some reports indicated that The New
Mutants would add a new character during its
time in post-production hell.
ScreenRant speculated the newb might be Warlock.
In the comics, Warlock is a techno-organic
alien who can shapeshift into just about anything,
including once into the famous starship Enterprise.
Director Josh Boone reportedly wanted Warlock
in the film, and said he planned to introduce
the hero in a potential New Mutants sequel.
Later in March 2018, The Tracking Board reported
something very different.
According to the site, Jon Hamm was set to
appear in a New Mutants post-credits tease
as the villain Mister Sinister.
This would have connected back to previous
references to the villain in movies like Deadpool
2 and X-Men: Apocalypse.
This idea was eventually scrapped, after which
reports emerged that Antonio Banderas had
been added to the cast in the role of a villain
whose identity if he's even actually in the
movie remains a mystery.
If The Tracking Board's report is accurate,
then it leaves the question of why Mister
Sinister was cut from the film.
There's been no firm word, though some have
speculated that Disney's acquisition of Fox
is mainly to blame, and that Marvel Studios
wanted all references to early X-Men films
cut from the film.
Of course, we should mention that by March
2018, when the Hamm/Sinister report surfaced,
Disney's acquisition of Fox hadn't been finalized.
As of now, we really don't know what happened.
We don't know a lot of plot specifics for
The New Mutants, though we do know some interesting
details.
In 2017, Entertainment Weekly said a source
close to the production described it this
way:
"Held in a secret facility against their will,
five new mutants have to battle the dangers
of their powers, as well as the sins of their
past.
They aren't out to save the world they're
just trying to save themselves."
That seems to jive with what we've seen in
The New Mutants trailers.
In both the first teaser from 2017 and the
most recent trailer, we see the mutants in
a hospital where Dani is subjected to painful
tests, and all of the heroes react to some
kind of unnamed supernatural horror.
In the newer trailer, we see Dani finding
what appears to be a force field on the edge
of the facility's property.
As Ilyana tells her,
"This isn't a hospital — it's a cage."
There's also strong evidence suggesting the
early New Mutants villain, the Demon Bear,
will feature in the film.
The villain is known to feed off the negative
emotions of its victims, which could connect
to a moment in the newest trailer.
"This place takes your greatest fear and makes
you live through it until it kills you."
The fright-heavy first teaser for The New
Mutants dropped in October 2017, and at a
glance, you'd hardly know the film had anything
to do with Marvel superhero characters.
The more recent trailer that debuted in January
2020 isn't that much different from the original
in tone but we do get to see more shots of
the characters using their mutant abilities.
We see Rahne beginning to change into her
wolf form, as well as a brief shot of Roberto
in his Sunspot identity.
There are a couple of shots of Sam's powers
appearing to emerge.
Finally, the trailer ends with Illyana, dropping
from one of her teleportation discs and holding
a bright sword, her eyes glowing with similar
power.
Dr. Cecelia Reyes spends a good amount of
time in the most recent trailer seemingly
trying to figure out the mutant powers of
Dani Moonstar.
We can't say yet what will remain similar
between the comics and the film, but in the
source material, Dani's main power is related
to her codename Mirage.
Dani has the ability to reach into the thoughts
and emotions of others and produce hologram-like
images based on them.
She eventually even learns to weaponize her
abilities by stunning her enemies with arrows
she creates using her psychic powers.
She's also shown the ability to create strong
empathic connections with animals, which has
helped her communicate with Wolfsbane in the
latter's wolf form.
In the comics, Dani has another set of abilities
that have nothing to do with her mutant powers.
Because of a classic 1985 crossover that played
out between New Mutants Special Edition #1
and Uncanny X-Men Annual Vol. 9 and took place
mostly in Asgard, Dani gained Valkyrie abilities,
including the power to foresee someone's death.
While she wasn't born with these powers, they've
become important parts of the character, and
would have obvious potential in a horror film.
We'll be curious to see if director Josh Boone
has chosen to incorporate them or not.
Will The New Mutants be part of the MCU?
Most likely, absolutely not but we're not
going to be 100% sure until the movie is actually
out.
Early in January 2020, reports indicated that
The New Mutants would be considered part of
the shared MCU narrative because of a description
in Disney's own D23 newsletter.
The email newsletter touted The New Mutants
as a, quote, "seriously electrifying new addition
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe."
Not long after readers took note of that specific
wording, however, Disney removed the MCU mention
from the newsletter and deleted the article
from its website.
Still, there was no indication of whether
the mention of the MCU was removed because
it was inaccurate or because it was something
Marvel Studios didn't want unveiled.
The following day, IGN reported that it could
confirm that The New Mutants would not be
part of the MCU, however the article announcing
this confirmation does not mention any sources
not even an unnamed one.
The only proof it presents is that the original
D23 article has been removed... which on its
own doesn't prove anything.
Regardless, it would seem very strange for
Marvel Studios to choose to introduce the
X-universe into its narrative with a story
conceived of and created by a team outside
Marvel Studios.
So while we can't say with 100% certainty
that New Mutants isn't in the MCU, probably
don't expect Wolfsbane and Cannonball to be
hanging out with Groot and Rocket anytime
soon.
Watching the New Mutants trailers doesn't
feel all that different from watching an advertisement
for a horror movie, because that's exactly
what The New Mutants is meant to be.
Director Josh Boone, a self-described Stephen
King fan obsessed with both horror stories
and Marvel Comics, has created a story about
heroes who, according to EW's unnamed source,
"aren't out to save the world they're just
trying to save themselves."
A month before the first trailer dropped,
then-CEO and Chairman of 20th Century Fox
Stacey Snider described New Mutants in an
interview with Variety as a, quote, "haunted
house movie with a bunch of hormonal teenagers."
She also added that it felt more like The
Shining than any contemporary superhero fare.
Likewise, New Mutants star Charlie Heaton
described the movie as "full-fledged horror"
in April 2018.
So, yeah, judging by those quotes and the
trailers, we feel pretty confident predicting
New Mutants will be richer in the screams
and poorer in, say, dancing baby trees or
long lost princes who talk to fish.
It'll be tough to list all the ways The New
Mutants strays from the source material until
the film is released, but from what we know
of the plot and what we've seen in the trailers,
there are a few obvious (and important) differences.
First and foremost, in the film these young
mutants are imprisoned in a secret facility,
while the New Mutants of the comics first
come together of their own free will recruited
by Professor X.
This helps to explain why the mutants in the
film are without the team's signature yellow-and-black
jumpsuits.
While the heroes of the comic were often concerned
with moving out from the shadow of the older
X-Men, the mutants in the film don't seem
to have any connection to the X-Men at all,
beyond being mutants.
One of the more interesting questions is how
the characters' powers will be portrayed.
The comic book versions of two of The New
Mutants' characters Ilyana and Dani draw more
upon the mystical world for their powers than
the average mutant.
The most recent trailer shows Ilyana wielding
her Soulsword, but it isn't clear yet if this
is meant to be part of the abilities she was
born with or, as it is in the comics, produced
by magic.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.